la ville de vous les dard est plongée
dans le silence
seul le vacarme des tirs d'artillerie et
les bruits de bottes viennent parfois
interrompre ce calme parent dans les
rues ou les soldats Ukrainiens restent
déployés ils résistent aux assauts de
l'armée des paramilitaires russes alors
qu'ils ont perdu des milliers d'hommes
dans les combats ces derniers mois
nous nous battons pour nos enfants pour
nos compatriotes ukrainiens et notre
nation
c'est un génocide des Ukrainiens et nous
n'avons pas d'autres solutions que de
gagner on se battra jusqu'à la fin
gloire le crâne
les militaires montrent une certaine
détermination mais il est difficile de
maintenir le moral des trous dans cette
ville minière défigurée par les
bombardements
comme abarthmoud plus au nord l'armée
russe est à l'offensive pour encercler
vous les dards il y a un soldat admis
là-bas est-ce que tu survoles la zone
ils essaient de nous encercler mais cela
ne signifie pas qu'ils y arrivent alors
on garde notre calme on sait qu'on ne
sera pas encerclé
selon les Ukrainiens mais elle est
presque totalement vidée de ses
habitants seuls quelques civils comme
Emilia et sa fille vivent encore ici
dans le plus grand dénuement
ça fait 9 jours que ma sœur est morte
on se sent mal on ne sait rien ne ce
qu'il se passe on n'a pas d'eau on a
rien là j'essaye de récupérer de l'eau
de pluie pour me laver les mains et
faire la vaisselle
et la situation pourrait empirer car les
forces russes affirment avoir coupé
plusieurs routes cruciales pour le
ravitaillement des troupes ukrainiens